hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that a lot of you have
requested throughout the years but i've
never got around to showing it and
uh here it is now uh john ludwig hammer
versus magnus carlsen is the 2003 uh
under 14 world championship that was
played in greece
and this is a game from round one it's
uh it's simply a brilliancy and it's it
would be a shame not to show this game
uh i have no idea why i haven't shown
him showing it up until now but
uh better better late than never so
without further ado let's check it out
and we're going to talk a little bit
more about the event afterwards
so hammer with the white pieces opens
with knight to f3
uh the ready opening is on the board we
have d6 by magnus
uh d4 and now knight to f6 we have
knight beat to d2 uh and
g6 now magnus prepares steffi and get to
his dark square bishop
uh we have e4 grabbing the center and
now
bishop to g7 and here bishop to d3 so
just nicely developing pieces
we have castles by magnus castles by
hammer and now
knight to c6 and this is all uh very
standard stuff all of this is still
played even today in 2020
uh c3 as the knight is attacking the
pawn uh so c3 defending the d4 pawn and
now e5 magnus strikes in the center
uh and here uh nowadays the the top move
is d captures an e5 also rook to e1 is
very popular
but in those days h3 uh was played so h3
and now uh as the air force square is
not covered by the bishop and the white
has somewhat
weakened his king side uh magnus takes
advantage of this and goes a knight to
h5 but this was this is all still
uh very very standard stuff and here we
have
knight to b3 is what is usually played
today
simply adding another defender to the d4
pawn now but here hammer played c
captures and b5 and now magnus doesn't
recapture
but rather remaneuvers the knight over
to f4 and this is where the fun really
starts here
uh hammer has to decide what to do as
his bishop on d3 is under attack and
best for white here is to just move it
but where uh well best is the c4 or
even the c2 but not the b5 b5 is not
the optimal placement for the bishop as
you'll see in the game but interestingly
whenever this position has been reached
so far and it has been reached in three
games so far
uh white always replied with bishop to
b5 because uh black's
maneuver is uh well not all that uh
simple to spot so here magnus went
knight
captures on e5 he grabbed this pawn
knight captures on e5 and now of course
white is expecting black will recapture
either with the d-pawn or with the
bishop but magnus doesn't recapture
rather goes queen to g5
and now you see the problem checkmate is
being threatened here on g2 and also
uh if white just moves the knight let's
say knight to g4 then
black has this option of picking up the
bishop on b5 which would not be an
option
if the bishop was for example on c4 or
on c2 but this is what you have to see
in order not to play bishop to b5 yeah
but it's all
obviously very very tricky to spot this
as everyone played bishop to b5 in that
position so here you have to decide what
to do if you go queen f3 to guard
against checkmate
then even knight captures on h3 is an
option because the bishop covers it you
will not be able to capture
uh the g pawn is pinned of course so
nothing happening there and after the
king moves just queen captures and e5
you're still attacking the bishop here
so black's position is just
excellent here so instead after this
bishop to g5 move we have knight
to g4 uh and now magnus just picks up
the bishop and b5 so it's
not nothing scary has happened just yet
uh but black did get a lot of
development in and now his pieces are
very active
uh so if uh bishop was on c4 or on c2
this all of this would not be possible
so you know if it happens in your own
games so knight to b3
uh continuing development also attacking
the knight here and here
magnus goes knight to e2 with check
which could be a bit dangerous
uh because it's not all that clear where
this knight will go after the rook
attacks it
so here king the h1 and now uh magnus
brings another piece into the game uh
while also eliminating one of
white's very active pieces so bishop
captures on g4 trading you're very
inactive bishop for
white's very active knight captures
captures and now
rook ate the e8 and here magnus says uh
i'm not worried about rook to e1 because
i can just capture on e4
and i'm gonna defend my knight that way
uh so here
bishop to e3 is played now blocking the
rook's defense of the knight after the
pawn is captured so rook to e1 is the
plan and uh
capturing the knight of course is the
plan however this completely
loses the game uh because here magnus
just captures the pawn
rook captures on e4 and now white says
okay
you grab the pawn but i'm gonna win a
piece here so rook to e1
but this is now uh this is not just a
check made in two moves so uh feel free
to pause the video and
win this game for 12 year old magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations
on summoning your inner morphy and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's a queen to h5 with check
and the way you spot queen to h5 is that
you see the knight is guarding these two
squares and
the king really doesn't have anywhere to
go if something
checks the king from the h file then
that's just it a
problem is you don't have time to go for
rook here because if rook captures
you're just going to eliminate the
knight and the king
gets access to the g1 square so here
magnus played
a queen to h5 check and now there is
nothing more to be done here
the king cannot move like i said these
two squares are covered by the knight so
the queen has to be accepted
this was played in the game and now
magnus just delivered rook the h4
checkmate and we get this beautiful
beautiful checkmate here
uh with a queen sacrifice and not only
that
uh the game actually no i think uh uh
okay let me just check this i don't
wanna uh i don't wanna
say it if it's not uh if it's not if it
didn't actually happen
uh but yeah uh no the game did not uh go
uh past the point of queen to h5 so the
game actually ended with queen to h5
check and this is where uh young ludwig
hammer resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
because after the queen is accepted
uh then just rook to h4 is checkmate uh
but yeah
really really awesome stuff uh 17 moves
uh
to end the game uh with the black pieces
in uh this
is the world championship under 14 world
championship but world championship
nonetheless
so really spectacular game and uh yeah
thank you again for suggesting it
everyone as a you know it's it's way way
overdue
uh of uh for showing this game as it it
is just amazing
and if you're wondering how magnus did
uh in the entire tournament he did not
win the tournament
the tournament was won by uh grandmaster
sergey gigalko
uh and also uh following were maxim
bashar lagrave maxim rodstein
and then uh fourth and fifth place were
shared by uh magnus carlson and
janiponici but yeah it was uh quite the
event and
interestingly 10 years some 10 years
after this game was played in 2013 where
magnus uh will be playing the world
chess championship match against
vishwanathan anand uh john ludwig hammer
was his only
second in the match who was advising him
via skype uh here we have a very nice
photo of the two of them i don't know uh
from when this
photo is but it could be from from 2013
it's hard hard to say
uh but yeah uh very interesting stuff
and i i think
uh magnus uh holds the record along with
bobby fischer for having the least
seconds in the world chess championship
match is here magnus uh as far as i know
only had john ludwig hammer who was
advising him via skype and uh
fischer only had william lombardi but i
don't think uh
i i don't think fisher was actually
taking any advice from him
i think he was just you know uh using
him to carry his bags or maybe you know
grab him a meal or something but but who
knows maybe he did
analyze some uh you know postponed
positions or something
uh but yeah uh that's uh the game i hope
you guys enjoyed it
uh i mean uh it is really really a
beautiful game so i
i was actually very happy to show this
one today so feel free to always use
hashtag suggestion and always suggest
beautiful games for me to show
so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank tomas
kucla dominique reichlen
uh bachar altzein uh mole petrol and
mick flannery for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day